but i i do think it's interesting we're
talking about guns with ukrainian
citizens i i the question i have i guess
is
if these these these like liberal types
not leftists left us like guns these
liberal types are cheering like occupy
democrats cheered for the distribution
of 18 000 i think it was you know select
fire collision cops full auto rifles
you you said like why don't you want
that for us and i'm like it's an
interesting question why do they want
ukraine's borders protected
and the people armed and they want the
people of the united states disarmed and
our borders porous and weak because they
want russia broken because they're
they're russia phobes because they
listen to the media russia folks yeah
they're russia there's a lot of russia
okay sorry i'll let you finish that and
then i'll go to my article
it seems like the liberal people that
are acting is is a fractal behavior of
the liberal economic order which has
literally gone around the world setting
up military bases and disarming
countries like japan after world war ii
arguably justified i don't know um but
the fact that they would be like stand
down get rid of your nukes ukraine
like that's that's basically what these
liberal people are trying to do to
american citizens get rid of your
weapons guy like either fallen orders
fall on the path you know they're
mindlessly whatever it is is that is
that going to be an effective human
civilization a bunch of sheep just
bleating about and then just eating
grass no i think diversity and con and
like resistance is more effective if you
look in nature that seems to be what
helps nature grow competition helps
advancements yeah you need a reason to
want to work for to go go forward you
just go forward because that's what
happens you got to want it yeah okay can
i
read you this headline so talking about
russia phobia first of all i want to
point out if you watch movies you can
always have a russian villain you can
always have like an east i even just say
a villain from eastern europe and no one
really cares right they're like oh yeah
that's fine but if you have a villain
that's you know uh i mean you could
maybe do this ten years ago but a muslim
or something people will lose their mind
there was an article in the globe and
mail today that said russians in the
sports world are doing pr for putin's
war machine
um
and they're talking about alex ovechkin
hockey player
and i'm sure do you guys see the tennis
player that wrote no war on the camera
yeah so in this article they're saying
all of that is pro-russia we need to
basic these athletes are all pro-putin
because they just said no war they
didn't say we hate putin wow and it's
like a full-on like hardcore kind of
anti-russian article and they're talking
about russians that are saying they
don't want a war and saying no enough of
that there was an nbc
i think it was nbc ex-executive that
said we need to start kicking russian
students out of america we need to start
seizing their property and i'm like
there are you know there are thousands
of russians protesting against this war
like russians are not putin you see
someone vandalized it was like a russian
uh club or something like russian
american club somewhere like smashed out
the windows
they banned all russian vodka
in canada that's right canada yeah in
lcbo i went and got a bunch of russian
standard vodka because they took it off
the shelves two hours after i
shake it up yeah the russian bath house
in manhattan is like the best bath house
in the world whoa whoa whoa whoa are you
are you broke putin yeah oh wait hold on
let me go tim we got to experience the
spanish flu and now we're getting to
experience cold war anti-russian
xenophobia how fun it's a you know you
gotta get
spice of life i guess yeah
we we had um that video from alex jones
where he was saying it's like a world
war one world war ii buildup and he
accurately predicted i mean as much as
he he predicted it he said back in uh i
think it was october that there would be
a big war in february so you have to
wonder yes yes where's that jar do you
have that jar somewhere oh it's
downstairs alex jones was right jar yeah
yeah he's going to be able to should be
more money in there already he has a lot
of good context because that was some
good info apparently but i also if you
look at like the way the world um
inflation is going you can kind of
predict a conflict on the horizon back a
couple years oh yeah yep price price
increases predict all of this stuff so
you look at what's happening in the u.s
and you've got all the tensions already
and now i'm i mean and how about that
the the russia phobia or whatever you
want to call it has been around since
2015 like they're the the boogeyman and
villain
russophobe but it's but it's but it's a
big component of the culture
as well no so look look
you get people saying you're a russian
bot you support russia they say tucker
carlson is pushing russian talking
points and it's like what did tucker
carlson say he said here's what the west
is doing in ukraine here's what putin is
saying and they're like ah he supports
putin yeah so what's happening
internationally is also a big component
of the culture war you add into the fact
that we already have terrible inflation
now this conflict is going to make gas
prices worse energy in europe is going
to get worse
escalating prices for energy and food
and then
shelter these precipitate major
conflicts internally yeah so
i gotta say man it just feels like
everything's kind of falling up i was
thinking about how um you say cultures
or politics downstream from culture and
i was like yeah really i want to help
the world if i was trying to get
everyone fresh water and internet if i
do that for someone that's the enemy of
someone else that someone else is gonna
be really mad at me that's right because
that's gonna help them grow and produce
more humans but if i'm an entertainer
and that person is watching my movies
their enemies don't care in fact their
enemies are probably also watching my
movies that's the beauty of
entertainment it connects people osama
bin laden was playing final fantasy 7.
he played animal crossing what
absolutely he was a human being who
played like
they don't
humanization is a problem like if you
come out and you talk about why does
vladimir putin want to do this what are
his intentions then you're pro-putin
like that's literally what they said
about tucker carlson well this is that
that phd guy i was talking about it
terrifies me how little we understand so
in china and russia they understand us
very well we do not understand the east
but they get us you'll see it even china
will come out and they'll be like go to
the united nations and they'll be like
oh look at america we need to deal with
america's racism problem george floyd
woohoo like as if they aren't super
racist there a lot of people anyways
obviously not all um
and there's definitely a an
unwillingness to understand them because
it's like that's humanization you have
to leave them as inhuman if you even try
to understand the eastern perspective
then you're pro-putin you're pro-china
um it also scares me and i wanted to
kind of talk about this quickly if you
guys are willing to but
when we talk about making political
decisions in the west it's on a
four-year cycle
it's just based on election cycles with
putin with china russia it's all like
hundred year cycles you've seen china
with the south china sea that's been a
hundred year plan we're gonna slowly
take this we're gonna work on this and
putin how long has putin been at least
20 years yeah he's been in office ages
but they're looking like a long time
we're not so they're like uh short-term
pain economically now for ukraine what's
that looking like in 50 years for us
that's how they're thinking well there's
a terrifying reality in that
to an extent authoritarianism is
efficient
the problem is the problem is if you're
uh
people always get mad at me when i say
that and i'm like it is that doesn't
mean it's effective
efficient different so here's here's
what i mean let's say you're you're in a
car
and you're driving straight towards the
edge of a cliff and there's one guy in
charge and every single time someone
screams and yells we're headed for the
cliff he says shut up i'm driving you go
off a cliff just just just it was it was
fast it got the job done real quick and
then not effective
if you had everybody in the car arguing
over what to do
you know eventually someone screams and
says you've got a turn and everyone says
turn and say okay fine and they turn you
know go off the cliff so the
decentralized system of power things can
be sluggish but in i think you're
offered up more opportunity for averting
disaster with someone like vladimir
putin he can move very quickly in a
single direction
china can move very quickly in a single
direction they can wipe out a whole
bunch of houses and then build a highway
that sucks for the average person and
then what happens is centralized power
limits your pers your ability to to see
what's going on a decentralized network
of humans who are running something can
come up with way more solutions and then
eventually the meritocratic solution
finds its way to the top not always with
authoritarianism
you got one really smart person you know
a philosopher king or a despot either
way they can say don't do this it will
be bad for us but they also are just one
person not the smartest person in the
world and they're not able to see
everything and they'll miss you know you
put it this way 99 problems they find
one they solve it very quickly it's
efficient in the long run they miss out
on all the other ones so i think
decentralization is the safest path
forward but vladimir putin china they're
able to is it the safest when you are
competing against people that can move
quickly because i think it's the safest
on a worldwide scale but not when you
have competitors that can go like i
think there's another answer here i mean
i i don't think it's so black and white
so i agree with you that it's a huge
issue that our thinking is so short term
in the united states i don't necessarily
believe that long-term thinking is
incompatible with a decentralized system
you just have to have a population that
is virtuous and intelligent enough to
want to make decisions that will be
better for the future so as it happens
our culture is really bad
at cultivating virtue and encouraging
people to move in a direction where they
will make sacrifices today for a better
future tomorrow if we were better at
doing that we wouldn't need some kind of
insane authoritarian system for people
to make decisions that would actually be
good for their children so a really good
point is
when you have a unified culture
you could theoretically have a despot
but no one cares because they all agree
with the direction the culture is going
in
so if the people if the people of russia
are all like we like what putin is doing
it's part of our you know our beliefs
and our ideology are they really going
to be upset obviously there are people
protesting i'm not saying they aren't
i'm saying if everybody in china agrees
with chinese communism and are willing
to make sacrifices for the greater
culture then well i think part of happy
with it i think part of the problem is
and so for the united states even though
we've always had these four-year
election cycles for the presidency we
were able to progress towards
goals that took us quite a long time and
that was because for the most part we
were on the same page culturally a
different political party
taking power from the political party
that was just in power for four to eight
years didn't really mean the country was
going to move in a radically different
direction so you could achieve things
that would take decades and decades to
achieve because no matter who you voted
for they'd be interested in that now the
difference between the left is so
massive and we
completely disagree on what's good for
the country and so that doesn't mean
every single time power changes hands
our country moves in a completely
different direction we can never make
any real progress well let's let me let
me clarify that see i think you had a
little bias there sheamus you're
assuming they're operating based on
what's better for the country they
aren't no they're not objectively not i
would agree that they're not i mean if
you're for open borders if you're for
non-citizens voting if you oppose the
constitution
you're literally not for this country no
i i agree no no no look here's the issue
i never said they were for the country
you said
i'm i'm being somewhat facetious but
you said deciding on what's best for the
country oh yes they're not they're
they're actually arguing what's worse
for the
country would agree i would agree so so
but here's my issue
i have if you're if you're of the
opinion that america sucks and the wokar
and it should be dissolved or destroyed
or overturned or dramatically altered or
should be a revolution fine just say it
just come out and be like we hate this
place and i'll be like all right like
just be honest with me about it well and
that's the thing a lot of them do and
then we're still willing to engage in
conversation with them about what
direction the country should move in
well i mean like the democrats like the
actual political class and the neocons
of course
the democrats and the neocons though
it's been like a fascinating trend to
watch some of the people that hate this
country the most be right-wing
nationalists
have you not seen the memes where people
are like hey you're a fascist you're a
bigot you're a white male we hate you
and then hey man come and go to war with
russia with us and they're like no
f you i hope you die yes
like they're like i hate this country
now i hope it collapses um john
doyle did a whole post on it and he's
like you know this is
we're in a regime that is conquered by a
globalist liberal power and it's crazy
to see you know nationalists being super
against america well so uh interestingly
i uh stephen marsh we had him on the
show he wrote the book the next civil
war he made he he summarized in a way i
hadn't heard someone summarize it i
think he nailed it he said within the
united states there's a multicultural
democracy and a constitutional republic
and they can't co-exist and i was like
oh you nailed it i mean that explains i
mean they want to get rid of the
electoral college which would be
devastating insane yeah they they they
they're for open borders to a great
degree i don't you know they always come
out and they nitpick it's like no to a
great degree they um they've been you
know the democratic establishment's been
smuggling my migrant children illegal
immigrant children across the country on
planes on military planes they're very
much at odds they don't believe in the
constitution then they but here's the
issue i take
if you want a multicultural democracy
okay present your case make your
argument go vote let's let's let's have
that conversation um
the problem is the lying
they come out and they say we're for
this country and the constitution let
800 000 non-citizens yeah new york and
you're like they're not citizens that's
the thing so
being for the country and being for the
constitution are different because the
federal reserve was formed literally the
bank of international senators this is
like a mind worm in our system it's been
in there for like over 100 years and
that is the country so i don't love that
but i love the constitution well yeah no
no no but hold hold on look ian if a
brain slug landed on your head and took
over your body i wouldn't say well i
guess ian's got to go i feel like get
rid of the brain because you know me but
everyone that saw me hey ian's acting
crazy
right that's right and it's been 100
years or whatever or like so you have to
detect what the virus is all pointed out
i want to point this out tim you're
talking about the fact that these people
will not come out and say that they hate
the united states of america and at some
point and i'm sure you agree with this
i'm sure i'm not going to get much
pushback here but we'll see at some
point they don't really have to it's
like that person who tells you they
don't hate someone but then every single
thing they say about them is bad and
whenever they talk about the goodness
that they might potentially find in that
person they say well they could improve
in this way they could hold themselves
to the actual standards that they've
said like okay you hate them and i'm not
gonna be all that surprised if you're
actually rooting for their downfall
instead of trying to make them better
because everything you say about them is
critical all the time criticizing them
in good faith is different than
criticization
i agree with you the issue is there are
a lot of conservatives there are a lot
of moderates and libertarians who think
that the left is being honest when they
say these things
like uh you know so again to throw it
back to the conversation with stephen
marsh i said you know in california they
tried repealing their civil civil rights
legislation or provision from their
constitution you know they they actually
are in favor of segregation he goes yeah
well they're saying so were you and i'm
like and they're lying well they say
they're saying you're lying and i'm like
yes but they literally tried to pass a
proposition to repeal the civil rights
language in their constitution i didn't
and i'm not i'm not sitting here
advocating for any conservative to do
that either i'm saying hey don't
but the problem is for a regular person
you know he he was saying look i'm about
30 000 feet watching this thing and then
i'm like and you need to dig deeper to
see exactly who really is lying and
telling the truth that's what i want to
what's the mind worm what do you think
it is what do i think the mind the
liberal economic order yeah i think it's
the downfall of liberalism right now i
mean you've had communism failed fascism
failed liberalism went forward and was
successful but it's something that it
may last longer but it's still coming to
the end of its life it's eating itself
is it classical
i want to respond to that so liberalism
is failing but not um as an ideology
unto itself communism fails because
communism is psychotic and doesn't work
liberalism failed because liberalism
allows
the the the malignancy to come within it
but is it the classical liberalism was
working and they changed the definition
of the word liberals and just reused it
for this new military
but you have the freedom to do that
that's what he's saying it allows the
freedom for that distortion because it
allows so much freedom and then here's
what happens
when uh when i am weak i ask you for
freedom because that is according to
your principles and when i'm strong i
deny you freedom because it's according
to mine so what happens is we have these
liberals it's it's happening like true
liberals like classical liberals like
civil libertarians it's all of us when
we keep saying things like look i
understand this far leftist is saying
crazy things but i have to respect their
right to free speech and they go thank
you so much ban him he's a bigot and
then you and then you get banned so we
we all keep playing fair and saying we
have principles so we want to uphold
them and they say thank you for doing
that you know not but deleted a good
example of how that can also work uh in
in your favor in that situation like
majid nawaz was in prison for basically
in egypt for terrorism he's on joe rogan
great show you guys got to check this
episode of groundbreaking um and
it was uh amnesty international he was
like anti-authority anti-west you know
anti-everything he was like a terrorist
basically against the west and amnesty
international still wanted him free
because he was being unjustly held and
he was like why why does this
this idea of this liberty this western
thing want me free even though i want it
destroyed because that's the pre that's
the idea of freedom is that we protect
your right to protest the system and he
was never he'd never done any violence
you know he's just been talking thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you